[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une formation de mécanicien
j'ai travaillé comme à mulhouse y est
charpentier
bref je sais quoi faire de mes mains
c'est également artiste et pendant de
nombreuses années je réfléchis à un
concept architectural qui part de l'idée
qu'on vit de nos habits mme zoabi sens
commun des enveloppes corporelles
mais on vit également de nos habitations
et je me disais nos habitations pourquoi
ne sont pas également comme une
enveloppe corporelle à l'image de
l'homme comme un organisme architectural
un jour la menuiserie de mon village est
à vendre
je l'achète pour réaliser mon idée
évidemment je vais à la commune je vais
trouver le service des constructions et
là je leur demande est ce que il faut
mettre l enquête
une vraie d'art alors là la responsable
et construction un peu interloquée mais
gardent comme ça la très chic et je dis
ah bah ça tombe bien je viens d'acheter
la menuiserie du village je vais en
faire une oeuvre d'art alors là il
déroule à la wii mais alors attention
parce qu'il ya des normes il ya des
alors bon après moult consultations
discussion ils me donnent toutes les
normes à respecter elle me donne plus ou
moins carte blanche
du coup au coeur de cet espace de cette
menuiserie
j'ai créé un système cardiaque
le fourneau
à bois avec un système d'aspiration de
l'air froid dans une zone de l'espace
comme elles sont bleues sont vingt
hommes qui a aspiré par le choeur un qui
est redistribuée comme le sang artériel
de l'organisme pour réguler la
température de l'espace évidemment fait
que tout doit être vrai dans tout doit
être humanisée cette cheminée ce foyer
est une sculpture une expression
poétique de vainqueur
j'ai d'abord également un système
digestif le bore apéritif pour se mettre
en bouche la cuisine on va élaborer les
animaux la salle à manger on va
assimiler les aliments évidemment tous
les détails sont travaillés lemoine
tiroirs le placard le vaisselier pour
qu'elles m'ont tordu mais c'est comme ça
que à cette chaîne n'est ce pas et ouais
fallait panser quelques microbiote
intestinal
n'est ce pas dans un organisme autour de
bactéries dont hymne qui sont ont fait
déjouer que je fabrique avec mon petit
enfant qui a trois ans pour qu'ils
apprennent tout de suite à travailler à
savoir travailler de ses mains donc
petit perceuse à colonne petite scie
électrique pas cette obligation de
modules hic de modules ludiques petits
microbes y est de l'espace légèrement
surélevé au dessus du système digestif
un système pulmonaire avec des barrières
évasée ouverture la respiration londres
on va reprendre son souffle
on va se retrouver soi-même et
maintenant nous allons pénétrer dans la
zone crânienne de l'organisme la zone
crânienne peut-être dur souvent ça
dépend qui met en général
à l'intérieur de cette tête minéralisée
se trouve la substance nerveuse
totalement dévitalisés
support de l'activité lumineuse la
conseille donc toute l' architecture se
minéralise devient comme de la lumière
cristallisé comme de l'optique et aux
fesses et on pourrait dire une
architecture qui de par ses formes va
appeler une activité limpide de la pompe
c'est une activité cristallines de la
pensée c'est à dire un espace idéal pour
par exemple à une zone de lecture une
bibliothèque
ils ont des réflexions de méditation et
dans cette zone crânienne j'ai également
placé la salle de bain et oui parce que
bien se rendre compte que notre cerveau
pour s'émanciper des forces terrestres
doit baigner d'autres liquides il est
enveloppé de l'équipe d'un donc il faut
que jamais du liquide dans la zone
crânienne de l'organisme architectural
et oui
d'où la salle de bains et si maintenant
nous quittons cette zone consacrée à la
conscience éveillée et nous pénétrons
dans la zone consacrée à la conscience
au sommeil nous trouvons trois petites
chambres comme des aéronefs qui va me
permettre de partir la nuit dans le
monde des rêves petite chambre à nouveau
totalement minéralisée cristallines des
fenêtres triangulaire et tout le
mobilier évidemment est élaboré pour cet
espace adapté non
si mano nous quittons ces froides
régions polaires de la zone crânienne
monde rationnel avec une pénétrons des
les chaleurs des trois pics de l'abdomen
le monde de luxuriance de vitalité nous
arrivons dans un espace où toutes les
formes sont arrondis courbe spirale plan
torsadé courbe de fibonacci nombre d'or
et cetera et cetera géométrie sacrée et
c'est un espace qui de par sa forme sa
configuration appelle le mouvement la
volonté l'activité toutes les parois
sont molles très dur moore toutes les
parois sont molles c'est à dire que je
les ai réalisées avec du tissu recouvert
d'argile des shows de plâtre et c'est un
espace qui est fort mais on pourrait
dire selon les principes de la dynamique
des fluides donc une acoustique
exceptionnelle et qui fait que nous
accueillons régulièrement les musiciens
des artistes pour les concerts des
spectacles
ils veulent profiter de cette oeuvre
d'art totale
il vient de participer au mouvement est
la vie de cet espace et cet organisme
architecture elle est un indicateur du
mann heat et en commun diapason c'est un
jardin dans lequel peuvent germer
fleurir les fleurs de lys graines de
l'esprit humain
c'est un jardin cosmique finalement
cette maison a été élaborée totalement
selon les normes conduites d'eau et
électricité isolation hauteur des
garde-corps pour les balles comme dans
une sécurité absolue
on ne risque rien dans un organisme
architectural mais d'autres dont les
normes ne pêche pas d'être poétique
être artiste est mon souhait serait que
un jour de plus en plus de
et on vit de la bord et leur maison dont
expriment de cette enveloppe corporelle
et c'est ce que j'appelle le coefficient
poétique un diapason humains inducteurs
d'humanité merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]